it's kkb let's go
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome your
host to the 17th annual igf Awards Gabe
Newell thank you
ladies and gentlemen
Gabe Newell
okay I'm being told that we couldn't get
Gabe Newell ladies and gentlemen your
host of the igf awards notch
not just in here either
since when does he own a yacht
whatever uh let's ask if Tim Schaefer
can do it
he's already he's already doing the game
developers Choice Awards okay
um
oh God please don't tell me we have to
get anti-shots
Nathan Vila the hell is Nathan Villa
ah screw it
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome the
host of the 17th annual igf Awards
Nathan Vela
good evening everybody
welcome
I am your third or fourth choice host
for the igf awards I'm Nathan Vela and
I'm really excited to be back here again
this year
it's a really big honor
I love you too everybody thank you so
much shut up
shut up thank you now as you may or may
not know I'm the co-founder and
president of toronto-based Studio Cappy
yes
I like that
so last year we released Super Time
Force
uh
yep thanks that was Chris Chris our
creator director whistling there uh the
only one we also collaborated on Super
Brothers sword and sorcery EP
and right now our whole team is hard at
work on below
now this year marks our Studios 10-year
anniversary as an independent game
developer and it's a huge milestone for
me and our team
uh in case you can't tell this is
something that I'm super proud of and
thus I am bragging
now I'd like to point out that these
Awards cost a heck of a lot of money
without the support of platinum sponsor
ID at Xbox the platform sponsor valve
and the student showcase Platinum
sponsor digiben these Awards will be
taking place under a bridge in the
tenderloin
however unfortunately there still wasn't
enough sponsorship money to get a real
host
so all right so super exciting night
let's get it started right off the bat
with the very first award
here are your nominees for the Lucas
Pope award for excellence in being Lucas
Pope
the Lucas
for excellence in being Lucas cope
Lucas Pope
um
Lucas Poe
oh boy who's gonna win who's gonna win
and the winner of the very first Lucas
Pope award for excellence in being Lucas
Pope is
Richard hofmeyer
right so Richard couldn't be here
tonight
it's too bad
uh so I'm going to accept the award for
him I think that's a nice touch
uh he wanted me to thank a few people
starting with me obviously
and uh the other names I don't remember
I forgot them already doesn't matter
uh God or somebody anyways Richard
you're welcome
and great job
what a huge win for Richard Holy Cow
speaking of big wins for Indies this
past year had a heck of a lot of
milestones for our section of the
industry
Indies led the charge for the PS4 as it
had an amazing year
no no applause okay
I kind of expected Applause and got none
so that threw me off sure you know it
was mostly by giving away our hard work
for free with PS plus but hey we helped
uh twine gained massive prominence this
year it's here for twine
yep
it even got written about in The New
York Times which caused at least 200
people's heads to literally explode
so those guys Microsoft apparently they
bought a little indie game named
Minecraft for an unbelievable two
billion dollars which coincidentally is
the exact same amount of money that it
would take to find every igf entry from
now until the sun expands to engulf the
Earth
steam continued to dominate indie game
distribution thanks to well thanks to
every game ever being released on it in
fact while I said that last joke eight
games were released on Steam
well hey are good friends at Nintendo
really came through for the Independent
Community this year releasing a record
four games
oh yeah also the App Store continued to
make real waves for the Indie community
and you can either wait 10 minutes or
pay 99 cents to see how
no topical humor free to play jokes not
not going over well okay that's fine not
funny I guess seriously though it really
was quite a year for us independent game
developers out of 2014 can someone came
some of the most unique interesting
artistic and important games that our
industry has ever seen tonight we're all
here together to celebrate those games
tonight we're here to give them fancy
awards that are sure to be confiscated
at airport security especially if you're
wrong
tonight we've all come together to
celebrate the true joy and Artistry in
independent games like Patrick Smith's
metamorphibit a game meets Toy about
everyone's favorite 26 letters
we're here to celebrate the narrative
creativity of inkles 80 Days a true
modernization of the Choose Your Own
Adventure
full of mechanical camels and floating
cities and other things that Jules Verne
would have been terrified of
Jules Verne joke
we're here to celebrate Clay's invisible
ink
love that one it's a turn-based
grid-based awesome based stealth game
actually while I'm up here I got a favor
for clay where's Jamie somewhere around
here
um could you do us a favor and maybe
stop stealing all of the good ideas
and maybe while you're at it stop taking
all the sales as well maybe leave some
for us no Jamie's shaking his head no
he's a selfish [__]
tonight we're all we're all here
together to celebrate games like 11-bit
Studios this war is mine
amazing game it's a game that took our
industry's propensity towards glorifying
war and flipped it on his head in the
way that only a small band of Polish
Indies could do
we're here to celebrate Crow teams FPS
Puzzler the talus principle
it's a game that I would love to say
something nice about if I hadn't gotten
stuck trying to get that star near the
pillar you know that one it's it's just
insane I have no idea how to get it
actually let's not celebrate that game
and we're also here to celebrate games
like outer Wilds that show the beauty
yep
outer Wilds absolutely outer Wilde shows
the beauty of the right kind of Jank and
how that Jank can be combined with great
game design to generate something
totally new and extremely fun
these 17th annual igf awards are a
glorious mix of perennial Indie Heroes
alongside first-time nominees and even
first-time developers these games and
all the other games nominated in each
category represent the breadth the 2014
had to offer in independent games
so I guess we should probably give them
some real Awards
DJ dropped the beat
that didn't work at all
so for our very first award I'd like to
suggest that everyone put on your
headphones
crank your speakers to 11 and get ready
to buy the inevitable the inevitable
vinyl release you [__] hipsters
oh no you don't like that oh vinyl
sounds so much better than digital oh
and so much better than all of you
also please make sure to pick up the
Super Time Force in sword and sorcery
12-inch LPS on bandcamp for the low low
price of 24.99
hipsters
this past year independent games
generated some of the most amazing and
craziest Sonic experiences that we've
all ever seen or heard
these five were the best of them the
finalists for excellence in audio are
excellence in audio
ephemeris of Musical Adventure developed
by super chop games
Matt Meyer
phono path
developed Pride Kevin
landmarks
the sailor's dream
developed by some logo games
the sailor's Dream Team
Shovel Knight
developed by Yacht Club days
Jake Hoffman
The Vanishing of Ethan Carter developed
by the astronauts Mika wise joinsky
Martin shivilovich
suffers
developed by Jewel
not heard
Brian Gibson
alrighty great nominees
and the winner of the igf award for
excellence in audio is
first one
ephemerate
wow
I'm not from San Francisco but the
tenderloin under a bridge sounds pretty
good to me
um
I don't feel like I'm supposed to be
here
um I did not prepare a speech
thanks to everyone who gave ephemerate a
chance it's a small weird game and it's
cool that events like this
I actually put it out in front of people
so
I just want to say thank you very much
to my lovely wife Soraya who could not
be here tonight and uh there should be
more wailing rock guitar in games
so let's face it
every single person in this room thinks
that they're a game designer
ideas are a diamond dozen but most of
our ideas really genuinely suck
great ideas are rare and even rarer are
the people or the teams that can take an
idea and mold it into real design
see great game design is The X Factor of
game development if you have it
shitty programmer art and a wall-to-wall
poker soundtrack won't matter you've got
a rad video game
if you don't got it all the high-res
textures and Ultra Real Models and some
banging dubstep can't help you
these five nominees for this year's igf
excellence in design award clearly all
have it let's take a look at the
finalists
foreign
the talus principle developed by protein
Dave ortonski
Tom Zuber
Jonas key roxies
80 Days
developed by April Studios
Joseph Humphrey framed
developed by Love Shack
Joshua dogs
all year round
Adrian horn
Stuart Lloyd
invisible e
well advice
by Jason Draeger
James Lawrence
Jamie Chang
the clay team
outer Wild
developed by tea hour ones
Alex Beach Andrew Goldstein low and dry
over nitrogen ends
Killer Queen
developed by Joshua device
alrighty
I like that we're all clapping for all
of the nomination packages it's really
it's it makes me feel really good about
it
okay and the award for excellence in
design goes to
outer Wilds
so when we started outer Wilds we just
wanted to make something where the only
point of exploring was to learn more
about the world and there would be no
objectives there would be no missions
and we just weren't sure people would be
into it so thank you for being curious
to explore this this janky world we
created
um and a big thanks to the USC games
program uh the Laguna College of Art and
Design and Atlantic University College
um clearly could not have done it
without any of them
thank you
and now please enjoy the comic stylings
of the amazing hey Ash what's your plan
don't repeat that okay but yeah he's
doing fine thanks for sending over all
those igf games by the way it's really
cool to see you know with gaming getting
more diverse that there's a whole
diverse roster of game streaming to play
he's been really enjoying them what's he
playing now what are you playing skating
this war of mine what no no no that
game's for adults play something sweet
like metamorphic this is the only game
Mama beef curtain sent me why did you
tell him to call you that don't listen
to Uncle flask
you already know the alphabet now it's
time to get your GED in w-a-r Stephen
Stephen close the computer my people are
starving they need food or they're gonna
die
hmm and what do we do about that Stephen
close the gate midnight so couple next
door has lots of food and are they armed
my sweet baby girl you stop it
it's so easy
boys got a big choice to make
just turn it off we'll play donut County
oh it's Stephen we've had good lives I
feel weird
Steven turn it off
time
sprouts
Stephen come inside Lunch is ready
my name's not Stephen
it's sweet man cheaper
this guy is the funniest
back in the day when Vincent van Gogh
invented painting he could have never
predicted how far art would come
and he definitely couldn't have guessed
how far art and independent games would
come because they weren't allowed to
play video games in the medieval times
the five nominees for excellence in
visual art couldn't be any more
different but they are all God damn
beautiful
here are the finalists for excellence in
visual art
excellence in visual art
donut County
developed by Ben Esposito
else heartbreak developed by Niklas
okerblood Tobias Shaw green Eric swedon
Oscar rydelius
Luminosity
developed by state-of-play games
Luke Whitaker Catherine Bidwell Daniel
fountain
Katrina Stewart
memory of a broken dimension
developed by xra
Ezra Hanson White
Oconee developed by
xxiivv and Coco robot
Rica Bellum Devin Lou Lind Vega
metamorphibettlers developed by Patrick
Smith bugs
l
I don't know how you pick one
and the winner for the award for
excellence in visual art is
metamorphibant
foreign
well thank you
I'm truly honored I've never been to a
games convention before
and the number of
amazing
brilliant and kind people that I've met
in the past few days
might exceed any other period in my life
tenfold I think it's really a great
thing you're doing here and I'm I'm
truly honored the other games all look
phenomenal and you should check them all
out
thank you
so everybody having a good time we're
enjoying
woot woot
so up next is the narrative award and uh
let me set up the story for you
a group of civilians from a war-torn
country set out to circumnavigate the
globe but after making it to Iraq they
returned home to New York City and all
come out as bisexual to their
conservative Asian AI construct parents
via text message all while driving a car
through a thunderstorm
okay is it just me or does that match up
of all the nominated games sound pretty
freaking amazing
would you play I would play that I would
totally play that
so these games aren't about being able
to mash a to skip cutscenes their game's
about narrative their games driven by
storytelling here are the finalists for
excellence in narrative
80 Days
developed by ankle Studios
John ingold Meg Giant
Joseph Humphrey
coming out simulator 2014 developed by
Nikki case
this war of mine developed by 11-bit
Studios
mihao drozdovsky shemek Marshall Pavel
mihovski
three-fourths home developed by bracket
games
Zach Sanford John Sanford
icebound developed by down to the wire
Aaron a reed
Jacob garby
thank you
pry
developed by tender claws
Samantha Gorman
Danny canizarro
alrighty
in the igf award for excellence in
narrative goes to
80 Days
foreign
isn't the game industry in a fantastic
place right now
which kind of throws into shop relief
what I was going to say I started off
writing text Adventures 15 years ago and
they were so dead no one even bothered
to say they were dead
um so we made a text Adventure so thank
you for taking it into your hearts and
bothering to read the words because I
hope you found they were worth it thank
you very much this is incredible
no thank you
now there's one thing we learned this
year it's that average
self-identified Gamers really celebrate
the work that we're doing here
that's why we asked a bunch of people
with egg avatars and anime names what
their favorite game was
this award is super exciting
well I mean it's not really that
exciting I mean it's like it's nowhere
near excite as exciting as like a low
speed llama Chase through Arizona and
it's definitely not as exciting as that
chase ending with a dude in the back of
like a shitty pickup truck lassuing said
llamas and then awkwardly bro hugging
his llama chasing Pals so let's say that
this award is moderately exciting
this award comes directly from the fans
it's time for the audience award
there's no video I just I just open it
up
and the audience award for 2014 goes to
this war of mine
wow this is very amazing thank you very
much now there's gonna be a bunch of
Polish names you won't understand so
thanks to jagos
thanks to the team thank you
foreign
stands for social justice Warrior
sausage Jew winter land
salmonella Jew wedding why do you keep
saying Jew
Santa doing it means social justice
Warrior what's that it's a derogatory
term for people who advocate for
socially marginalized groups
it's a bad name for feminists
it's a bad name for women are cool
people I'm a women are cool people does
that mean I'm a sensual Jew Whisperer
social justice Warrior and yeah sure
social justice warrior
in a world on the brink of collapse
there's only one dude bad enough to take
on the women ain't that cool people
please
do you believe there should be more
diverse representations of women in
minorities and games what about this
list of five games with non-objectified
female protagonists the existence of a
few exceptions doesn't erase the
enormous disparity in representation in
the industry as a whole
being social
and delivering Justice
social justice Warrior welcome to
patriarchy
I'm not a misandrist
I'm just pissed
okay that was awesome uh Round of
Applause for hey Ash what's your plan
they're the best
the best
and now we've come to the Nuovo award
which recognize recognizes excellence in
being so far off the beaten path that
even the word game has kind of lost all
meaning and is now just a weird abstract
sound
these pieces of interactive art are
unique to our industry and this award
celebrates the diversity they bring to
games
now at this point I would like to take a
second to ask all audience members to
make sure your minds are totally open
your third eyes fully aligned with your
chakras
and also double check that your USB
vaporizers are fully charged
it's about to get gloriously wonderfully
different
these are the finalists for the Nuevo
award
Nuovo award
boundin
developed by game oven
Adrian D young boyan androsky Bart
deleeson
Ernst baisner
elegy for a dead world
developed by digibon games and pop
cannibal
zyba Scott Rohit shenoy Luigi gautieri
Ichiro land
how do you do it developed by Nina
Freeman Emmett Butler Jonathan kitaka
decky cause
okay
rooftop costs developed by Stephen
Lawrence Clark
tetrageddon games
developed by Natalie lawhead
become a great artist in just 10 seconds
developed by Michael bro Andy McClure
desert golfing developed by Captain
games
Justin Smith
Plug and Play
developed by better Studio no Michael
Fray no Mario Von rickenbach
foreign
what a crazy bunch of games I love it I
love it and the Nuevo award goes to
Tetra getting games
um I'm not too sure this is real right
now
um
there's so many games I was rooting for
I was actually expecting a become a
great artist to get this
um
being part of the Indie Community has
been life-changing and I it's
unbelievable so thank you everybody and
for making all these beautiful games and
I'm honored to be part of this community
thank you
one thing I know for sure is that
independent game developers have a lot
of free time on their hands to just sit
and think
so while I've been sitting and thinking
I've been wondering what are they
teaching kids these days
actually it turns out they're teaching
them how to make [__] awesome
boundary pushing games that will lay the
foundation for the future of our medium
people like yeah all right
Go Kids
in my old age
I I'm getting a lot older so in my old
age I've really come to detest the
success of people younger than me so as
I present this award please remember
that the smile on my face is entirely
fake and inside I am a white hot pool of
jealous rage
here are the nominees for best student
game
in showcase
rooftop cop
developed by Stephen Lawrence Clark
apartment
developed by team apartment
Robin Gray Richard MS
ragava bashial Philip Eberhart
close your developed by Goodbye World
games
William hellworth
John Billingsley
Graham Parks Keenan mosimon
downwell developed by ogiro fumoto
even the Stars
developed by Paul Clarissa
Nicholas Gavin
Gemini
developed by Echo Stone games
Atlas Chen Nick Jong
Kevin Chen
Tony eon
interloper
developed by monagan games
Simon Nas
Maxim Shoemaker
ingmar udabas
Bart beermas
Stellar smooch
developed by Alec Thompson
Jenny Jiao Shaw
and the award for best student game goes
to
close your
thank you
so wow
this event is the difference between
People Like Us students having to work
day jobs at McDonald's and becoming
independent game developers so it's so
meaningful to us thank you so much thank
you to the team thank you to my
girlfriend who kept me alive uh
this is unreal thank you thank you thank
you I also want to say thank you to our
producer Anais uh I don't think we would
have got as far as we could without her
we're sorry if she couldn't be here but
thank you all at USC
thank you
please give a warm idea of Welcome to
the winner of last year's Seamus McNally
grand prize Awards Lucas oh
you win a couple of awards one year
and they write you into a huge
show opening joke the next
heads up that's fair warning for
everyone else
so hello again I'm back
uh-huh this time for a slightly more
legitimate award I think
I just want to quickly say that I did
come up here a couple times last year
and I have very fond memories of
standing on this spot of the stage right
here so thank you all again very much
for that
okay enough about me I'm old news
thankfully
we've got a new grand prize winner this
year so let's check out the nominees
Seamus McNally grand prize
the talus principle developed by Crow
team
DeVore hoonski
Alan ladavats Devore tomichitch Evonne
Mika
80 Days
developed by ankle Studios
Joseph Humphrey John ingold
Meg Giant
giama fabregat
invisible ink developed by Clay
entertainment
the clay team
outer Wilds developed by team outer
Wilds
Alex Beacham Sarah shali
this war of mine
developed by 11-bit Studios
mihao drozdovsky shemic Marshall
Pavel mihovski
metamorphibet developed by Patrick Smith
Sarah Alder orbit David comp
ostrich
log
okay they're all good games
all right the 2015 Seamus McNally grand
prize goes to
outer Wilds
foreign
I've used up everything I was gonna say
um thank you so much this is insane um
and we're just I'm just tremendously
grateful that for the team
um and for all of their hard work and
for all of our crazy players and people
who traded stories on the internet and
discovered that you can actually outrun
the Supernova which we didn't even know
was possible
um thank you for yeah exploring and just
everything thank you
thank you
well they left their envelope
huh
what a huge win for outer Wilds holy cow
and what a huge night for independent
games
and for a predominantly white male game
developers
it's hard to look at any of the winners
as underdogs and it's even harder to
look at any of the runners-up as losers
considering the amazing caliber of the
nearly
650 games submitted to this year's igf
that's seriously it's an amazing fee
now I'd like to take a second I'd like
to take a quick quick moment here uh
everyone down there everyone in the in
the seats right in front of me here if
you were nominated for an igf award
whether you won or not get out of your
seat stand up please stand up don't be
shy get up yep let's give them a huge
round of applause everyone
I love it
I noticed somebody was standing on a
chair without a spotter that's very
dangerous
so before I get my ass off stage so we
can start the real game developers
Awards
that joke
there is one last little rant that I
kind of have to make
this past year has exposed a lot of
hatred and some significant
unpleasantness in our industry as of
tonight there continue to be women
people of color
and lesbian gay bisexual trans and queer
artists who are being trolled and
spammed and threatened and doxed and
hacked and even driven from their homes
it's no longer possible for those of us
in this room to ignore or minimize these
issues with our industry or these issues
with our art
I know you all believe it I know you do
this
thank you
I still got more so you might maybe
don't need to see I'm kidding but just
as this year has exposed all that
ugliness it is also exposed a new
generation of creators and activists who
are fighting for video games and video
game culture they're fighting for us the
independent games community
I really don't think that they want our
gratitude at all I think they need our
support
I think they need us to work together as
a community to show people a new way to
engage with each other and play
so let's all fight back against this
hate the best way we know how through
our games and through our teams and
through our collaborations
let's make sure our games aren't
embodying any stereotypes or caricatures
let's make sure as a community we are
supportive of one another and we are as
welcoming as possible to any and all new
voices
to me this really gets to the core of
what it's about to be an independent
developer we don't have any stock prices
to fret over we don't have any
entrenched political dogmas we own our
art
this gives us a real opportunity to be
the change that we all want to see in
this industry and I think that we it can
change for the better together
I'm a little bit intense there sorry
I'd like to say thank you to everyone up
front and in back thanks for putting up
with me again this year it really is a
massive massive honor for me to be up
here on stage cracking pretty shitty
jokes and also getting to hand out
Awards to all of the people that really
inspire me and my team back at Cappy
also again I would like to really thank
the crude ID at Xbox the team at valve
and everyone at digipen for sponsoring
these Awards
we thank them
and we're done folks uh I'd like to
remind you all please stick around
because coming right up is Tim Schaefer
and the game developers Choice Awards
presented by the all-new Mountain Dew
Kickstarter it all starts with a cake